yeah the U.S has been watching this
surveillance balloon for the past few
days before revealing anything publicly
they are now saying that they very
strongly believe that it is a Chinese
surveillance balloon and it's over the
state of Montana and specifically the
city of Billings in the south southern
part of the state you can see pictures
and videos that people have taken on the
ground quite clearly puzzled about this
uh strange object in the skies above
their city if you look at it it looks
almost like a small version of the Moon
and it's presented this conundrum for
the Department of Defense and for
President Biden about what he does about
it they're saying at the moment they've
decided not to shoot down this balloon
for two main reasons firstly they're
concerned they could have heavy
machinery attached to it and if they
shoot it down it may result in a large
debris field and risk to civilian life
on the ground secondly and crucially at
the moment they say they don't believe
that China is receiving any Strategic
Benefit fit from this balloon then they
would be getting from ordinary satellite
imagery but it is interesting that
they've chosen to situate the balloon
over the state of Montana Montana home
to one of only three U.S military bases
in the United States which specializes
in intercontinental ballistic missiles
although the Department of Defense not
saying publicly that that's why they
believe that China have flown it there
but certainly interesting timing from
the US in publicly disclosing that they
believe there's a link to China because
we're just a few days away from a visit
that the Secretary of State Tony blinken
um is taking to Beijing where he's
expected to meet with the Chinese
president Xi Jinping and certainly this
episode is doing nothing to dilute
tensions between the two countries
we're in the last hour China has
responded here's what the foreign
Ministry spokesperson Mao ning said a
little bit earlier
China is a responsible country and we
act in accordance with international law
we have no intention to violate other
countries sovereignty and Aerospace and
as I said we are gathering and verifying
the facts we hope relevant parties would
hand I would handle the matter in a good
headed way